[Music]
hello guys welcome back to just kidding
news we are doing conspiracy quarter
turn up putting your hands like this
right now
then you're not [ __ ] woke to the
movement you're not either or you're
against us look at Chris you Chris watch
that be like eh you never said Chris
today we're doing Mandela effects hell
yeah what is the mando oh yeah oh it
actually is like there's actually a
distinct definition I always say it it's
like when the collective has the memory
of something that never actually
happened like it doesn't actually stop
me other words in the matrix actually
we all remember something that never
happened exactly like Nelson Mandela
died but he could not die that's where I
started off from because they thought he
died in prison but then he went on to
become the South African well he died
now but now he actually is maybe ten
years he didn't die can't die because
then it ruins the Mandela effect mmm
it's true but the actual definition is a
recent refinement of false memory that
typically refers to pop culture or
current event references for example
your favorite peanut butter which a
peanut butter and butter no Jeff there
you go I said it already
oh yeah actually no it is diff I thought
it was jiffy you should be listening to
my white voice combining Skippy and gin
oh is that what because yeah yeah what
do you picture what do you picture jiffy
what do you picture like turquoise at
the top oh I do Peter turquoise is
turquoise I picture those colors cuz
jiff has those three lighter color bars
right do you guys remember peanut Peter
Pan peanut butter oh yeah they didn't
yell like buster for like Salmonella or
something it never existed through what
Peter Pan peanut butter
and now what this one for Julia Julia
you're the Pokemon expert here sure
so Pikachu yeah his tell what's on the
end of it the tail yeah a pill black
black it's yellow
good job you are to focus my fan there
is no black tip the brown it's brown no
like really anywhere except do whatever
is right yet last the fake one the the
one the left the fake one and he [ __ ]
up he was used to hell who plugged him
up
no somebody went back in time and they
ruin the space-time continuum enough
where some of us remember it's real can
you thank goodness because Pikachu looks
a lot better right now can you explain
why it's called the Mandela effect is
because there's a collective memory of
that people have of Nelson Mandela dying
in the 80s like a lot of people remember
specific articles of him dying in the
80s but he didn't die ladies he died in
the 2000s I wouldn't know I was a baby I
wasn't even that part yet use Febreze
II sometimes you spell febr3 there is
there is no second Eve there's no it's
like for prez yeah but that makes no
sense I'll call for fries you know the
commercials say Febreze
so did 9/11 happen or what it happened
but not on 9/11 it was actually August
8th or it was on October 9th did you
notice that 9/11 only happened on the
news people never died they never
existed does this apply to like the
Berenstein bears yep that's another one
that's the one it's actually in here
Berenstain Berenstein just like what's
what's that Mandela effect on that so
remember a Berenstein bears yeah so in
everyone's head they thought it was
spelled there in steen like they're like
st ein yeah but if you go back it's
actually Berenstain yes the berenstain
bears he a I am hmm
I thought it was themed yeah and then
there's a lot more I think it's cuz kids
are stupid and they just sound it out
right
that's how my parents told me to and it
just catches on air by Belize my pet you
into the life my parents are fake news
mixed up with Yogi Bear to Mason stuff
and they teach a lesson where's the dad
the dad had the green hat right what
knows brown hat need a break see nothing
like a poofy brown hat with a feather
like leprechaun hat
no no I good I think it's a brown hat
with like a poof at the top and then you
have like a yellow shirt with okay
you're right
that's so weird
so what bear was I thinking the one with
a freaking collar and a tie and in a
green hat yogi I get the whole video
tell your ex I think you people [ __ ] for
anything oh yeah people didn't remember
tell your ex Pacific speaking of
speaking of I think that the mendel
effect is affecting Joe right now cuz he
thinks that jackets in style you about
anything by the way did you buy that
shirt good job people saying you wear
the pineapple shirt too much I'm gonna
buy you more clothes okay and until you
ended up oh so that's the start of the
month this is the debut the official
debut that's a nice shirt by the way
good job Nikki thank you I've also
bought him a yellow plaid shirt and I
like that one even better hmm is it
playing like I am these shirts he
doesn't buy it himself it's a new thing
this year because yeah he'll just wear
the same shirt over and over again so
this year I was like okay I'm gonna make
it a point that every time I go to
Target I'm going to buy him new clothes
so that we can cycle it into his
wardrobe but then I haven't been going
to target Mendel effect I checked my
closet sometimes there's new clothes in
there
but you collected we collectively
remember you only wearing exactly
sometimes they just stay in the bag in
his office forever I'm like you haven't
worn the pineapple shirt in three months
and you finally busted it out the Dean
told me he's possibly sees me in the
pineapple shirt because JK is behind by
three months anything a vlog with you in
a pond officer and that was anything
else with you every day to remember told
to recycle like hey you couldn't wear
the other shirts I bought so you like
cycle them in don't be like it got
wrinkled I'm like he doesn't do anything
it just sits wrinkles for like guys I
wash it no we watch it hanging up
immediately yeah no you do not wait do
you don't dry it you don't dry it in the
in the dry no no no no no it's rigged so
secretly I just want Steve to have seven
oh those pineapple shirt and then each
of them have a label like one of the
season does when you actually went to
Islam I'll be Steve Jobs only pineapple
shirts that's why you only does if you
get different slightly different colors
like for each pineapple while I go yeah
like the Luke I am your father line that
one I always knew because I watched Star
Wars my first so it's not I am your
father
no it's it's no I am your father not
Luke I am your father there's no Luke
ever inning your child if I try to be
like no you're wrong it's Luke I might
do that
I've watched no the all the times
because if everyone agrees on something
you're the dota 2 when they did a parity
oven they said Luke so everybody once
they watch The Simpsons and that just
trickles maybe I got it from yeah
Simpsons yeah ages trickle is that mean
that collective everybody just like
playing to that same they probably do it
for the copyright well maybe I don't
know there might be a trademark on that
line oh and then like everyone
remember Sinbad being in a genie movie
yeah good memories of him in a genie
costume I have him to have him to write
was a they look nothing nothing like no
Sinbad super like in my mind I have him
in that year the turban in him with all
of the shoes and everything
yes and I'm like why wasn't he in a
genie movie why hasn't anyone done it
since well I think he has done something
was wired genie movies not in right now
right get on came out with Will Smith as
the genie oh that wasn't Sinbad as the
genie no I was good
Forrest Gump Forrest Gump which is
famous Y&G life is like a box of
chocolate I never know what you're gonna
get we talk about I love it was it was
was didn't say is he say life's a bus he
said life was like a box of chocolate
but it's like a box of chocolate it's a
really small yeah but he also sees also
talking weird he also talking with some
people on when he's gone top him bit
mine Jenny
[Music]
say me or do you remember him saying may
that's so small what did you guys be
gonna sexing when you were that when you
were young and watching it I like tall
sexy and I watched it like well he has a
team sexy because every time there was a
sexy movie my parents would freak out
about it a couple dress so I always try
to peek because like what the [ __ ] are
they hiding even I knew he [ __ ] like
an idiot lady really big cutaway not
that one the mom had sex with what do
you made those noises and he came out
he's like your mother really cares about
your education that was really good
there was a sex scene in Ventura that
was during the same time period so
there's a sex scene and Ace Ventura like
that song in the jungle wait what sex
scene are you talking about before is
the UH pets
oh no I I was talking about the Jenay
one when he actually got with her but
then he started away yeah I remember
that scene you guys remember the 90s
Demi Moore being incredibly sexy yeah
yeah she wasn't she had really oh he
needs their disgusting
well what about them someone asked him
to detail his trolls I mean I enjoy
pressing him for it because that means
he has to like think a little more
instead of just throw anything out there
just like oh God thinking hard as
nothing I ever do that's true that's for
damn sure
hello Clarice what's what's a never
happy what really what you think ladies
no never
never say he liked favio fava beans
never says her name ever [ __ ] movie
he never says my cycler eats my he never
says hello Claire he's like the whole
thing everybody
that's like saying he doesn't say it
puts the lotion on the skin he just says
it's lotion time it's lotion time baby
like a 90 scared like it's loosened or
he just throws away he's like it's
lotion time it's lotion time baby much
malleson no I think is because this is a
collective lie I just was perpetuating
it like like even with language like we
have different terms that come out like
that's not how that was said but like
night it used to be good night
really yeah it just evolved like we just
took off the K like it this love it
words like that language yeah or if you
might really think about like poles or
it used to be sordid oh I even like
phrases like hello oh that's a whole
nother something like a whole another
whole another like remember what they'll
be like it's a gay old time oh yeah oh
yeah that's not going to it some least
we took off the tee like it's not
Flintstones its Flintstones another
Mandela my favorite Mandela effect you
guys one of my favorite Mandela fact of
all what so we all remember Josh leaving
Jake a party right but what I remember
some of us remember is that Jake a party
ended anyway had Josh said he quit
[Music]
you
[Music]